[Musique]
on m'a dit que vous étiez une tripotée
aux meules à magoar ça le premier gendre
pourquoi tripoteur cli porteuse parce
que si le mot qui convient puis je te
porte toujours de la chair fraîche
voyez
[Musique]
je pense que vous faites mais ça a l'air
bon ça sent bon ça commence à sentir bon
et oui ça je fais fondre du gras dira
qu'on a sorti du cochon on a tué le
cochon madame agouazi oui monsieur
inconscient demande d'une belle pièce et
trois cent 300 il faisait 150 kg 150 kg
c'était une belle pièce on c'est dommage
vous n'étiez pas venu le voir hier au
qu'il était beau bien installés sur son
sol en ce moment qu'est ce que vous
faites vous préparez donc tout
alors maintenant nous préparons nous
allons travailler nous avons faits dont
les boudins et aujourd'hui nous faisons
gratton pathé
et là soute il ya 25 ans que je fais ce
manège dès le début je n'étais que
quelques-uns mais par la suite c'était
chez pierre supporter les charges atelio
mais je sais pas j'ai tout le monde je
développe mon salon je gagne un peu tout
la comté juste applis dont dieu que je
vis là là après avoir assaisonner les
saucisses pour amalgamer tout ça je
pétris pour que tout chaque bout de
saucisse et son grain de sel poignet il
faut être costaud parce que euh c'est
lourd déjà et on ne dirait pas méga 10
kg de viande va dedans comme vous il
faut très peu 6 1% comme marcel de tous
côtés parce qu'on ne trouve personne
et c'est là réseau moi je suis toujours
depuis que je suis à la retraite et je
lui ai dit a longtemps dû lâcher la la
rampe
mais pourquoi en vigueur qui n'était pas
d'un si jeune dejan a aucune qui se
lance entre ça nous rapporte pas
c'est encore assez délicat de faire ça
et les passes ne sait pas toujours
tutour mais l'huissier vos cuisines
aujourd'hui je fais bien nommé je fais
mal
vous avez dû en faire des kilomètres de
saucisses je vous dis j'en ai fait oui
des kilomètres on me disait d'ici
bordeaux au même peut-être plus oh oui
ça va être mangé comme ça à demain au
besoin sur soi si on veut nous pour noël
avec des huîtres c'est ça on fait cuire
l'association 608 avec des huîtres
oui et que c'est très bon qu'est ce que
ce type était sonné pâté de foie
confectionné avec le foie du cochon reid
et du la moitié moitié
un petit peu plus peut-être pour qu'il
soit pris - le respect des goûters à
force de dentelle naturel cochon
étonnant que nous payons plus tout est
bon pourquoi accrue vous le manger aussi
a voulu monter comme ça pourquoi
pour eux c'est comme ça quand on goûte
comme des cons et dégustent alors voilà
alors comment il est au poil
après ben voilà
[Musique]
à